if you want to win championships and
eSports then keeping it simple in
crucial situations is your likeliest
path to success this is absolutely
perfect he's got the perfect angle
except it on the other side but
sometimes you just want something a
little sexier an act that will turn
heads drop jaws and send twitchchat into
an emergency state of boggers and few
plays and competitive gaming achieve
this more consistently than the fabled
noscope we need to change my pants
firing a scoped bolt-action rifle at
someone without zooming in can be either
an insane trick shot check this out dude
that's it that's it or a desperate
high-risk play getting pin set from both
sides
but before we talk about the dankest
technique in gaming we have to look back
at the evolution of shooters games
involving some form of scoped gunplay
have been around since the nes
although arcade titles like silent scope
and peripherals like the SNES super
scope allowed players aim at targets
through physical optics scoped weapons
were more of a novelty than a
standardized gameplay mechanic most guns
and shooters were just aimed from the
hip with no iron sights or scopes to be
found but in the late 90s and early
2000s games like Medal of Honor Jedi
Knight and counter-strike among many
others began to introduce the scoped
weapon views that we're familiar with
today even though scopes finally had a
functional use and were no longer just a
weapon aesthetic not all players were
interested in using them and while it's
impossible to know when exactly no
scoping was coined the term became part
of gamer discourse by the mid 2000s
strangely even finding its way into the
occasional rap song but it was the call
of duty and halo franchises that took
noscoping to the next level with
bolt-action rifles packing a serious
punch in both series players were drawn
to using them at all ranges and
consequently no scoping became a
celebrated tradition
the best call them an urban hump the
chest maybe just gone to the old school
halo 2 sniper rifle in particular
offered a generously accurate hipfire
reticle and as a result it became an
effective method of engagement
regardless of target distance but no
scoping someone wasn't just a strategy
it was a statement and in call of duty
this statement became young unlike in
Halo 2 Call of Duty's sniper rifles
lacked useful hipfire radicals so no
scoped shots were far less likely to hit
and ultimately more satisfying when they
found their target one of the pioneers
of these hype noscope reels was
youtubers ear Grizz who became known for
his modern warfare gameplay uploads
grizz's take on trick shots which he
dubbed gee shots became influential
enough that he had to release a video
showing full length gameplay to prove
that the clips weren't staged
before long the noscope was an essential
component of the trickshot montage
players wanted to see their peers
hitting crazy shots and content creators
were willing to record and package that
kind of gameplay into videos that drew
millions of views sniper clans like
optic gaming and faze became
institutional pillars of Call of Duty
thanks in part to this video format and
how it helped them build their
communities
these montages inspired players to push
the envelope and capture the most
outrageous frags and if the highlights
from faze ill cams weren't enough to
make your head explode they're obnoxious
soundtracks definitely would
[Music]
this constant search for the ultimate
unbelievable trickshot is how we ended
up with ridiculous [__] like the 360
noscope and absurdly over-the-top type
of kill that emerged around 2008 and
only grew in popularity during the
Golden Age of MLG Call of Duty it's
essentially gaming's equivalent of the
Vince Carter Duncan Pony Hawks 900 or
the mind-bending things they pull off in
dude perfect videos but as with
everything else in life people take
their enjoyment of things too far and
some truly obsessed noscope fanatics
have gone to the extreme of attempting
to pull them off in the real world
you see it oh my god
these days the cult of trickshot has
expanded beyond first-person shooters
into battle Royales
which have only elevated the bar for the
art form not only for channeling
fortnight in particular has encouraged
players creativity by offering tools
that allow them to challenge conceptions
of what is considered possible in game
no I just did not hit that but in
eSports where big cash prizes and titles
are on the line no scopes have become
worshipped legacy defining acts pros
deploy them as a risky answer to
desperate situations
okay tax up or has ostentatious ways of
flexing their dominance on the server to
Kenny first up the back he finds a shot
but he's being pressured up close he
need shots to support him he's watching
for a flavor would squawk oh my god
Kenny it's an incredible Gilligan sixer
but no matter the reasoning behind no
scopes
they're always hype and this is it steel
he can't get it with the dough scope tap
the palm once and cold is coming around
the boxes as well Kerrigan he knows him
no way oh [__] double smokes in the same
place s it with his jumping
simple I don't know man if he comes in
with that he had one button there was no
soon as one of the flashiest plays in
gaming the noscope isn't going anywhere
because as long as there are scopes on
guns they're going to be people that
refuse to use them for style points
speaking of flashy plays I can't believe
it show the cold zero jumping off
fortunately we used it enough this year
to hit our quota quota you know that
quota Dan it has been three months since
we put faker versus Ryu in a video seven
since the Olaf boost you need to get
your [__] together or so help me God
your ass is going to be on the street
welcome aboard
what do you got there you got some pizza
a pizza to go and no scopez it's a lot
of nonsense eSports is just a lot of
nonsense terms before we talk about this
technique in game
what's this next thing sound-up rekt
[__] 420
that's just like a clip what's the 420
meter what do you think that means here
we go we're speaking the Gino is
generation